I have a question from this lady here
um just correct me if in case I
understood drawing you said that men are
more clever than women
have I heard it correctly exactly okay
how you can
um how you can prove that they have very
big difficult medical things when
approvement Texas to part of brain and
show The Logical way for example if men
play chess he can play 10 steps they
make the same experiment with women can
be maximum five your brain not have
deepest level which have meant it's
approved it's approved if you're
interested it means IQ it's main IQ it's
meant how deep he can make if you take
all statistic woman we cook every day
but chefs is always men women can be
nurse but the biggest men who make
operation it's men women can help and
manage things but owner of business it's
man if you open the Forbes because I'm a
big research in my life and I have
academic two high education psychology
clinical medical psychology I work in
hospital and I have experience about
this and yes I can say with absolutely
numbers if you know new you can check on
Google here's something clever much
stronger also try to check in the tennis
faster because they have uh in all my
kids we cannot we cannot this lady in
the red is you know the lady in the red
is actually nailing it I mean it's and
it's a shame that women like the one in
the red get you know suppressed canceled
uh because she's actually saying common
sense you know I work just so you know I
work with fashion models in New York for
about 10 years I was a nightclub
promoter and I Pearl and I were talking
about this where the the Eastern
European models and comparing them to
the Brazilian models and the Eastern
European ones that were way more uh
traditional submissive
and they respected the man you know they
didn't give a maybe how he looked
Brazilian ones might have loved it they
had fun Playboy but the but the Eastern
European women they had a standard of
expectations of what they wanted from a
man they wanted a strong man they placed
that higher as a life partner but then
they were willing to give that in return
the problem is when women want all X Y
and Z but they're not when it suits them
but then they also want X Y and Z when
it you know they want their cake and
they eat it too man it just it can't
work that way it doesn't work that way
and I think you I think you you describe
I think I think I I don't have very much
discussion over whatever you said is I'm
completely disagree when you said men
are more clever than women because I'm
in clinical field as well okay so I'm
working in hospital as well and IQ we
have seven types I think seven types of
IQ that you know recognize we have a
sport IQ have a math IQ have it either
you can say generalize that women are
less clever how many discovered it has a
woman how many Discovery how many
discoveries has a woman okay how many
children have how many philosophic has a
women how many artists has the women no
open Google no this is billionaires
let's talk about the billionaires the
richest women billionaires divorce
that's the funniest thing the most
successful women got their money from my
divorce has my relationship with the IQ
no no but
I'm asking about outcomes so the women
with the most money how did they get
there was it was it they're being so
smart and competent
let's let's let's think about I'm
thinking about our female billionaires
one has a sex tape one sells makeup and
the others got their money Amex model
and I work in healthcare when Amex model
you're you're a model I'm a model okay
and you work in healthcare and I work in
a healthcare yes okay great and I have a
black belt in karate okay but I bet you
he could still say and if you say that
Romans are not clever
we can't say who is aware we have to say
I think we can look at the outcomes so
we could see who who is not an outcome
is which category you know the men can't
be a better Runner if the if they run
with women because they have
testosterone they have a bigger muscles
okay not because they are more clever
they active you know the sport IQ then
they hire but you can compare this lady
with this lady okay this man comparing
the man you said once one time you said
men are different with women their brain
is different their size is different and
then you compare the IQ together it's
absolutely wrong exactly absolutely I'm
looking I'm looking at
nothing I'm looking at what well I don't
not beautiful I'm not talking about
beauty no you said Beauty I said we
monetize I I said okay let's talk about
value added to Society what makes
Society run okay no no no no wait wait
wait wait wait wait let me let me love
you I need you remember remember
Mike again all right this is your final
warning one more time you're gonna go
okay so
I'm sorry
all right thank you thank you all right
all right wait what did you say
okay actually you can go now thank you
goodbye yeah goodbye um Security will
escort you out
wow yeah that's pretty yeah I I've
warned you like three times
to stop over talking me we read you the
rules at the beginning of the show it's
all right go ahead everyone
no all right and now you're gonna keep
talking back goodbye goodbye go please
wow
please exclude my conversation and
everything from this video no it's live
so I'll see ya
you didn't invite me I didn't want to
yeah but calling the people ask me
okay I put
okay all right I have eight years old
waiting for me okay all right I
mean it's very
very okay I mean if you knew all that
you could have just followed the rules
though
because
stop over talking and even while you're
doing it just now she still told you
okay stop stop but you just didn't yeah
y'all see how y'all see how
it's like y'all see how her emotions
just took over though right it's just a
clear example of how everything she was
saying was she doesn't like it
if you live and put a lot of time and
effort to come in Utah all right so
clearly that's a clear example can you
take her out please thank you
no no she doesn't no go take out you
take yourself okay no no no no no that's
not yourself no no no
no no please leave please leave
can you just leave please
this is this is the problem it's not
worth it please
no take her out figure out can I just
say I don't take her get out get out
hold on don't worry about it it's just
it's just a show it's just a show
it's just a show
it's just a show I respect you but it I
just just sit down and have a good show
I don't want you to leave no no good I
don't want good right now she's go just
please be respectful that's all she's
saying
okay yeah just watch out bro watch out
bro she's a black belt in karate
oh gosh
crazy it's like she's a black butter
karate that saying watch out she
foreign
yes goodbye goodbye goodbye
yeah exchange it outside
if it was because it's so disrespectful
I don't remember what we're talking
about
um
yeah as many of you know I was just
banned on Tick Tock and we are
demonetized on a daily basis on this
platform if you want to help please
consider sending a super thanks below
every donation helps and it helps make
what we do possible